This technique gives a beautiful finish
to the shoulder seams of garments.
Worked in the garment yarn,
or in contrast in colors.
It can add a designer
touch to your next garment.
Start by binding off your stitches
with a latch tool bind off.
You may also know this as a
round-the-gate-peg bind off.
Now, if your machine doesn't have gate
pegs or gate posts, you can still work
this bind off.
Look for the Knit it Now tutorial
"Stretchy Bind off without Gate Pegs".
You can also find the latch tool bind
off tutorial in the learning library.
The idea here is to utilize the chain edge
that's formed with this style of bind off
for our decorative seam.
Our sample is knit in stockinette, but if
your garment is knit in a stitch pattern,
maybe fair isle or tuck or you've used
short row shaping for the shoulders, be
sure to knitone plain
roll before binding off.
Now first align the seams
with the right side facing.
You'll pick up the bottom loop
of the bind off from the inside.
Join this loop to the corresponding
loop on the other shoulder piece.
Now keep working this way across the row.
Pulling the stitches
taught, but not too tight.
I've used a contrast in color here so you
can see the seaming stitches, the blue
seaming stitches.
When you're seaming with the garment yarn
and the seam is neat and tidy and it forms
a decorative Ridge on the
public side of the work.
To summarize, knit one row plain.
Bind off each of your shoulder
pieces around the gate pegs.
With the right side facing.
Pick up the inside loops of the bind off
stitches and join the seam all the way
across.
Pull your seeming thread taught.
But not tight and block your seam.
Don't try to hide your shoulder seams.
Show them off.
Thank you for watching.
If you'd like to see the other seaming
techniques available in the learning
library, please consider a
subscription to Knit it Now.
You'll have full access to all the
tutorials and many other benefits.
Happy knitting.